it was the worst industrial disaster in
India's history 30 years ago on the
night of December the 2nd 1984 plumes of
poisonous gas leaked from an American
run chemical pesticides Factory in the
town of Bhopal in central India night
people are dying on the streets
scattered like garbage thousands of
people like Sanjay Yadav lived right
beside the plant and no warning was
given the consequences were catastrophic
I lost my sister that night all night we
spent trying to find my family my sister
hadn't held a lot of gas her skin was
peeling off and her eyes not completely
white the disaster happened when water
accidentally entered a methyl isocyanate
storage tank triggering an
uncontrollable chemical reaction and
blasting a cloud of toxic gases across
nearby slums official estimates suggest
some 5,000 people died campaigners say
the real toll including those who later
succumbed to illness was around 25,000
the effect of the incident are still
felt acutely in Bhopal they are also
contested Sanjay Yadav sons Varun and
Amon were born after the accident they
were both born disabled doctors at the
Sam have no clinic who treat gas
affected people in Bhopal say higher
rates of children are born with
abnormalities after the incident 570
thousand people have suffered some sort
of health disorder related to the
disaster including cancer and
neurological problems 30 years on people
are still going to hospitals with gas
related illnesses
certain are sarangi is the managing
trustee of the some have no trust in
Bhopal the out of the 570 thousand or so
the people the problem is that the
government has take put too many of them
93% of them in a category of just
temporary injury but if you look at the
figures of the from the hospital records
any year's record even this year's last
year's record you will find that there
are more than 400,000 people who have
been visiting the hospitals meant for
gas affected people despite their
disabilities sanjay yadav says his sons
have been removed from the category of
gas victims at the moment he does not
receive ongoing support for his children
the plant that was the source of the
Bhopal disaster is still not secured 30
years on it's chemical waste
contamination pits still remain and the
area has never been properly cleaned up
even three kilometers from the factory
groundwater has been found contaminated
with high levels of toxic chemicals
Jevon Shinde is also from the town and
is a retired relief worker he was in the
original incident
Yohe we even today there are 26
settlements behind the factory the
government has declared that the water
there is poisonous and only some houses
have hand pumps and tube wells some
villages are getting clean water but
even now I have witnessed many residents
using the same blue water no
organization has taken full
responsibility for what happened in
Bhopal local politicians bears some
responsibility there was a failure to
secure the hazardous site to provide
good medical care for those in need and
to provide other forms of compensation
but most obviously to blame was Union
Carbide corporation the American company
that owned and ran the plant we have
organized a technical team which is
being dispatched to the facility was
operating below the safety standards I
found in its sister plant in West
Virginia although Union Carbide argued
that the accident was caused by sabotage
rather than shoddy equipment
long-standing Indian efforts to
extradite and prosecute that CEO of the
company failed he died in September
prosecution's did
progress though painfully slowly against
junior executives in 1987 Union Carbide
agreed to pay 470 million dollars in
compensation via the Indian government
that amount fell far short of original
claims for three billion dollars
individuals received twenty five
thousand rupees the equivalent of about
four hundred US dollars Hegira B is one
of the victims who received compensation
during a period of six years if one got
14,000 400 rupees and then ten thousand
six hundred rupees which totaled to
twenty five thousand then how is that
enough if one goes to see a private
doctor then the doctor charged a fee of
one hundred rupees government hospitals
were never reliable if someone gets
seriously sick and goes to a private
doctor then most of the money was spent
on consultation fees
Dow Chemical another American firm
eventually bought Union Carbide although
it claims that it bears no
responsibility for earlier activities of
its subsidiary campaigning groups such
as Amnesty International say the
opposite arguing that the firm has a
moral and perhaps legal duty to pay up
fully for the costs of the disaster
victims of Bhopal get justice then the
entire world will get justice as no
foreign company will have the courage to
run his poisonous business in any city
recently Indian lawmakers introduced a
liability law that holds foreign
companies unambiguously responsible for
accidents while that law may be intended
to protect people from future by piles
the reality is that environmental
disasters caused by industry are
affecting a growing number of Indians by
one estimate air pollution from cars
industry pharmacy burn fields and more
caused 627,000 parameter or deaths in
2010 alone and the new law does little
to help the survivors of Bhopal whose
lives have been permanently altered by
the tragedy
you know it's my children just sit all
day and watch TV what else can they do
they don't go to school they just stay
at home and kill time but in response to
criticism the Indian government recently
announced that it will revise the number
of deaths and injuries plus expand
compensations to victims yet as family
may get another chance but rupees alone
will not undo the damage that has been
done to the community of Bhopal The
Economist